e se tutti ragazzi e prendermi di questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo allora
e mezzanotte più o meno che meno a
mezzanotte e che cosa fa una persona
intelligente a mezzanotte gioca un
horror perfetto quando avevo costretta a
casa mia c'erano i miei genitori in casa
quindi più o meno che spuntava un mostro
dall'armadio c'era mio padre con la
mazza da baseball adesso manco per il
cazzo di ragazzi niente dire che
possiamo iniziare con loca e da un
casino che non usavano to treat
vabbè che bella ragazza allora crystal
reed facciamo normale che se non vuoi ma
che bello è una roba del tipo ah beh
bello il soffitto per i sette nani in
fantastico proprio c'è tocco con la
testa meraviglioso tensione non portare
tua nonna nel labirinto va bene grazie
farò presente quello è l'aria
condizionata non è sì ma che cazzo di
comandi assogget vado indietro come i
gamberi a sta facendo la grigliata lega
bellissima la volete una salsiccia o
rapporto io è una roba da troppo ma
prossimo che così di merda noi la
lasagna sta facendo la lasagna scusa ho
sbagliato pardon golette c'è la lasagna
ed è un [ __ ]
ma posso girarla visu edita locali che
mi sentivo un gambero andrà all indietro
così la gamba chemical fa un passo come
se fosse un chilometro torino milano in
una gamba da ciò la meravigliosa entro
la dentro con come se fosse una a
bastardi è proprio c'è una roba sentite
regala [ __ ] era un tipo è bello le
cuffie ragazzi fatemi capire cos'è il
tipo di prima che ha scoraggiato è
normale è normale
avete visto anche voi ragazzi avete
visto anche voi via via più veloce
veloce veloce veloce nel oggi alla conca
raja e bulgara chiave ma andando
esattamente dov'era quel tizio per
favore non vorrei sempre sa è una torcia
come verde deduco che se la si è
infilata al tizio di prima mette una
roba easy è una roba isis per un attimo
ho creduto che fossero dei ragni per un
attimo in joy del raid
serpenti ci sono degli spermatozoi a
forma di serpente dei serpenti a forma
di spermatozoi preferisco i pulcini e se
questo è un bild e vostro ragazzi
l'idolo posso prendere
prendiamo il deal dove diamo di riuscire
a prendere la chiave che è perfetto
scusate ragazzi non volevo disturbarvi
però per ora è il gioco horror che vince
la vita perché è stata abolita dal
soffitto rega ma che un po di contegno e
che è eva è la tipa con le mestruazioni
preferivo al vomito maestro o vomito
sceglietelo dai andiamo prima sul
maestro che oh che bel ancora ne voglio
avere gagno avanti prima che io posso no
in culo a mamma
devo fare va bè ragazzi non sono nato
funambolo è posso provarci però porca la
[ __ ] si pipistrelli di merda voi e
batman di sto cazzone vabbè ispanico il
panico ispanico sono un deficiente
veloce veloce veloce bravo che pro
argine ho preso la jam ragazzi devo
trovare anche quella verde la pozione
mica è una donna manco in gel da trovo
tutti sicuri che culo come faccio a
tornare indietro che figo cos'è acqua
frizzante rega non spunta la bollicina
che c'è nessuno se sta merda ragazzi
maestro è fatto adesso che sono la gemma
rossa devo provare il vomito andiamo sul
vomito ascolta zio e mangia meno pesante
e grazie se qua per caso ci fosse se qua
fa al caso passasse un [ __ ] di nome
fa vj ditemelo è proprio devo saper lara
pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa pa perfetto ma
si aprono bravi ma io sono una persona
con un quoziente intellettivo pari a
quello di un lombrico
come ve ne ha sparate ben due la prima
volta ti faccio al secondo buco del culo
e tele infine entrambe è roba bravo
bravo bravo complimenti c'è la mira
uguale a quella di mia nonna che tanto
non può entrare nella b riina e che
cazzo però ma siete seri
no no no succhia succhia e vabbè però
difficilissime se invece si va in
sembrava impossibile ma ce l'avevamo
fatta mi chiami stava ingrossando alla
fine c'è ma è una me è una melma verde
su facebook eri molto meglio però te lo
voglio dire non è che ti vuole insultare
comunque quella roba lì era tipo lo
slime di minecraft be strong and its di
only choice il web
sei forte e l'unica scelta che hai
questa sarà la prossima frase sulle
descrizioni di facebook di tutti qua un
po trovati cereali rega
ora la gemma perfetto soggiornare a casa
non si rompe st trave muoio prova sono
dettagli ce l'ho fatta sì c'è di nuovo
il vomito sì grazie
dove vado cielo tutte cielo tutte nel
culo perfetto con job ma [ __ ] e lo
so anche che c'è sto [ __ ] di
spavento uguale l'area che condiziona
ecco vedi piove anche qua non mi crolla
al soffitto addosso non so perché è
giusto dubbio choose your door choose
your face sceglie la tua porta scegli il
tuo destino
guarin zio destiny dragonball ecco tra
un pò guardà che sei figlio di vito a
madre ma proprio la madre è io so già
che qua deve cadere qualcosa minchia di
ricacciare lo so c'è satana che mi spara
addosso walk alone non ho lavato
stamattina giorno tanto non spunta un
cazzo perché c'è la caga giudizio stavo
scherzando
a regà bava chi è che ha parlato ragazzi
c'è una leva l'ho aperta non ce l'ho
tirata aperto qualcosa non so cosa
all'aperto sia come dio è una sfera del
drago lega possa evocare sharron me
manca un altro 6 però dilemma che ci
porteremo avanti per tutta la vita
perché io per devo prendere la sfera del
drago
invoco the cell the formation crystal
reed the stones of jazz and angels love
day 2 monsters co me ne frega un cazzo
di mostri ma qual è la mia amica
d'accordo ragazzi ho finito col tempo
dopo che questa era soltanto la demo e
il lattaio ho preso gioco completo
quindi se volete che io faccia il gioco
completo dovrebbe esserci altri mostri a
tre cagate peggiori fatemelo sapere
intanto che lo levo sto coso che gli
occhi così lasciare io mi piace per la
povera ragazza melma anche questa qui
che è triste comunque ragazzi concluso
che l'episodio è stato bello come andare
a un resort
come ha scritto sei video è piaciuta a
un certo momento mi piace anche la
facile di facebook e con i video trovate
la descrizione se avresti dissidenti i
civili devono prossimo vito e la ragazza